yanez mikhasti from technion on logic so
fine I think you'll arrive thanks a lot
for getting to listen and for the
invitation and for the atmosphere and
this talk is a variation of a talk I've
given for us birthday so there are a
couple of people here have heard it
before I make mistakes they can correct
me okay so I Met Your 39 years ago it's
incredible and happy to say this again
we stayed friends in spite of fertile
disagreements sometimes unfortunately
actually in the original set now in the
published version not in the slides
there were some unproven claims which we
claim that me we were able to prove or
didn't include in the paper and some
miss Prince so I shall indicate in the
talk where the problems are and i would
like to thank more its Miller from the
logic rope in Vienna who reviewed the
paper for math review and and stumbled
upon upon those things and was kind
enough to inform us before so the paper
appeared in projects in the fields of
our computations as a second volume of
birthday papers for Yuri and it is also
available if you are not in a library
on archive so what I'm going to do is
I'm going first to discuss the faith
among both theorem or finite structures
and put it in an abstract setting and
actually I've been curious since since
the 80s and I worked in abstract model
theory whether there is a
characterization of a logic satisfies
some kind of version of Pamela theorem
if and only if it looks like this or
like that and we actually see this in
the chapter of the big fat book without
an index which nobody can read and model
theoretic logics it's even asked as an
open problem whether we can characterize
logics with some kind of effluent
voltaren and then we have some new ideas
on how to approach this and I will spend
some time in explaining this in detail
you don't have to get scared it's about
Hank you matrices now uncle matrices if
you google them you get thousands of
paper in numerical analysis miss plenty
of applications everywhere but this is a
generalization of uncle matrices 222222
logic not to numeric values go to go to
structures so we just took over the name
because of the analogy and at the end i
will i will discuss some some problems
so first some notation if you have a
structure now structure the product of
two tau structure is the model theoretic
Cartesian product and actually constant
sometimes make problems but be kind of
brush over those problems the sum of 2
tau structures is the model theoretic
disjoint Union and generalized products
our first order transduction not
necessary first other word for the
practical process now first of all the
transactions of products so you can you
can redefine the predicate
using first of the formula and general
sons are scalar first of the transaction
of sons the difference is that in
products you can also say the new
universe consists of triples of the old
universe and in scalar transactions you
are not supposed to do this we also look
at at K connections k connections there
and actually the Haiku matrices are
called connection matrices in Lovers
papers see have a a graph we say three
ports one two three and you have another
graph three ports one two three and you
can take the disjoint Union but identify
those elements and we denote this as
disjoint Union 3 or k if there are K
such ports and these are called
connections rather than disjoint unions
and they cannot strictly speaking be
produced as as as transduction but they
behave in a in a very similar way so
these are K connections and actually in
lower this paper you can also have
identification which are more
complicated but I only deal with those
you could also say those two points are
identified across something on now and
then again generalized connections are
scalar first or the transactions of K
connections now the favor man wats erm
for for finite structures it just says
that if you take any of those operations
and you want to check a formula in the
product or in the summer general some
then you can reduce this to checking
many things in the components and then
some are piece them together using a
boolean function
than this precisely and we are a first
thing we have to discuss is what are the
logics on finite structures which
satisfy some version of the fifth man
both theorem so if we do this strictly
speaking so let this be a generalized
product on tau structures then there is
a at T natural number and a function row
mapping formulas into strings of
formulas with let's say it's given like
this where K is a national number and a
boolean function so the idea that this
is the formulas you check in the first
structure these are the formulas that
you check in the second structure and
then you look at the results you get
zeros and ones depending on whether the
test is true or false and then you plug
in those zeros and ones into a boolean
formula and you get one if and only if
the the product structure satisfies the
formula and using the components so just
talking about sentences at the moment
I'm talking about sentences they you can
extend this also to numeric parameters
and all kinds of things but here in this
talk I talk only about sentences okay
and the formulas which you get to do
this are called the reduction formulas
and the important thing is that number
of deaths you have to do doesn't depend
on the undersides of destruction right
sir and actually this was used in in
courcelles theorem about checking in
structures of boundary tributes because
the structures can be decomposed then
you can do some thing which people call
dynamic programming 2022 to compute the
variable
of the final structure by by climbing up
to three their composition
now the fabric Marvel theorem is also
true for infinite structures and can
also be cited for infinite products here
we are only interested in the finer that
actually did the tricky part of the of
the waveform and God theorem in the
original 59 paper is indeed that if you
take an infinite product and then you
have also to this house what happens on
the on the index sets but in the finite
case these trivializes now the venerable
theorem is also true for melodic
second-order logic if you take some like
structures rather than then products and
this was certainly known already in the
50s maybe then I can tell us about it it
turns out I always when I was a student
thought that price I was sitting in
aussieland and start scheming sitting
here I turned out they were all visiting
and discussing things together and
ultimately they presented the paper but
but is also saying that it's happened
independently it's not quite through it
happened collaboratively somehow with
several formulations of the of the serum
the version for monadic second-order
logic appears explicitly in law at least
66 paper which Sherlock didn't read in
detail and so he reproved in 79 and as
far as I know you really didn't
understand the sketch Sauron gave and
then he wrote the paper figuring out the
details which is rather tedious but all
this is difficult because of the
infinite case out of the finite case
and actually there is this parameter T
so so if you have a formula of
quantifier rank something q then the
reduction formulas may may have an
increased quantifier rank depending on
the character of the generalized some
more product depends on the on the
quantifier rank of the transduction but
if you just take normal sums or normal
products then T can be taken to be 0 and
this is an important ingredient in the
meta theorem so any also we can
reformulate now what happens in the
monadic second order case and now we
have some like operations are sorry some
like
is something where is it
maybe it should have been somewhere and
you know some light generalized sums are
arbitrary transduction of sums and some
like is if the transaction is quantified
free to make sure that the the t is is
zero and then we can formulate let the
Sun like operation on tau structures
then again there is a function and a
producing reduction formulas and so on
but now depending no no this should have
been some light issue that in
generalized some and you get plus T and
if you take quantifier free transduction
then you can take T equals zero and this
is the way it can be used for four core
cell serum on model checking for monadic
second-order logic now indeed there are
many algorithmic uses I have also
written a long paper on these with these
new applications also well then new
applications msl definable graph port
properties can be checked in linear time
over graph classes of bounded rivers and
and one way of proving it is just
proving the formal wat serum and then
then doing the dynamic programming part
we also have there as a use of this the
msl theory of graphs of bounded three
weeks is decidable my zsazsa we have the
msl definable graph polynomials are
computable in polynomial time over graph
crosses of bounty trivias which i
noticed first
if the class of tau structure has a
decidable melodic second of the theory
so does its closure under disjoint
unions you can play with this and but in
all these applications T equals zero at
least for our greeting parts is
essential for decidability it's not it's
not so essential so if you want to do
this into an abstract setting then we we
have to see what we what we can do now a
lien term logic is just an abstract
object that we have a set of formulas
but they are just names of something and
the set of structures and the
satisfaction relation and what what I I
would i add additionally is I want some
kind of a rank function it doesn't have
to be a quantifier rank but it's it
should be something which tells you how
expensive it is to look at this formula
so so in practical application did those
two usually they won use the quantifier
rank but in open problems will discuss
you could have another option if the set
of sentences in the end the logic is
uniformly computable then we call it a
ravaged logic motivated by by his paper
on the challenges and the road the rank
function is nice if it holds that for a
finite acabo Larry there are two logical
equivalence only finitely many formulas
of this quantifier rank which happens to
be true in in the applications but but
you can have a different rate function
and
see what what we can do you require just
that the syntax is computable no no that
everything is computable but you have to
be able to decide who is a formula many
of you if this would constitute a lot e
40 time is very essential that you have
effective compiler yes yes yes i was a
bit shortcut here now examples of nice
logics in this sense is first order
melodic second-order logic but also if
you add the modular counting quantifiers
you get nice logics so there dkm X V of
X means they are exactly K elements
modulo M satisfying fee but here one has
to be careful this is why I show this
example is if you take the normal
quantifier rank for this to be one I
mean adding one then all of a sudden you
get infinitely many formula of the same
quantifier rank but if you if you make
it dependent on on em then you can
satisfy so it is it happens to be nice
now indeed this additional there are
three elements modulo 5 is expressible
without the additional quantifiers but
then you have to write down first of the
quantification and to say that there are
there is one two three which are not
taking something to take them away then
then you get something zero module 0 100
m and so so this is a very tricky to be
nice one has to adjust the definition of
quantifying rank so if you take this
function row 1 then it's not nice and if
you take Row 2 then it turns out to be
nice for our purpose now for an abstract
framework row can be any function
attaching some cost two formulas given a
syntactic objects in concrete examples
this is usually some variation of
quantifying
but but maybe if you want to do I don't
develop this now hearing to depths but
if you want to define abstractly what do
you mean by such a cost function you
probably would add a condition that it
is weakly monotone with respect to sub
formulas a 5c is a sub formula feed and
the rank is smaller than smaller equal
and the rank of the big formula and
maybe boolean combinations of formulas
do not increase the cost but I don't go
into this now every abstract Linstrom
logic can be given the canonical syntax
by adding generalize quantifies for each
definable class obstruction if you have
a abstract logic and you just say for
every similarity type i introduce a
otherwise quantifier which says this is
the logic then you get some some crazy
syntax but at least you you can you can
give it a crazy syntax like this so in
English sense but then it into question
is how you define it is crazy centers
the quantifier rank such that the logic
comes out nice
I spoke before about translation schemes
a translation scheme is just an
interpretation by the way I look at it
as a transducer Lee given a structure
you apply you have a sequence of
formulas which define the interpretation
and you apply these formulas to the
input structure than the new relations
are defined by these formulas and you
get a new structure and then you only
have some some complicated or tedious
conditions about the compatibility how
the oddity of those formulas depends on
the singularity hype and so on but this
is what we mean by by translations game
now this can be defined for any logic
which which has notion of Lee free
variables but in the applications we
usually when we speak about some like
and these formulas have to be quantified
and free and if you speak of general
items and we allow here also
quantification and the quantifier ankle
of a scheme is just the maximum of the
quantifier ranks which appear in those
formulas
so the translation of a formula is
obtained the structure is mapped into
the new structures and the translation
of the formula is a backward
substitution and then you have a yes
okay so so as translation scheme is
scholar if k equals 1 if the formula
fears that doesn't doesn't increase the
parity so okay so I I said this already
so we have those operations and some
like and product like in contrast to
generalized just means quantifier ankles
and then we can reformulate what is that
way for more not property but you have
seen it already twice so I believe that
you can reduce afterwards yourself now
examples of logics that have to pay for
mental properties first other than
counting first order have it for product
like and first order and melodic second
order and so on have the property for
some like I i forgot to say so in the
abstract definition I want that the
quantifier rank of the formulas you get
is the same as the quantifier rank of
the formula you want to check
for some operations you have also first
order and melodic second-order logic
together discounting and the same is
true also for connection like operation
so here comes the question what can we
do to characterize logics which have the
pavement property for some operation now
an operation is smooth if it has the
property that if to see if two pairs of
structure satisfied terrorize the same
era q sentences than the applying the
operation also satisfy the same lq
sentences ology now if you have
compactness if you have compactness then
we showed in the very old paper with
Sherlock that indeed the converse is
true smoothness implies way from and
what and remember what implies smooth
but in our context where we are here
this is a useless remark it doesn't seem
to work in general so here is an open
problem find the natural example of a
nice logic and an operation such that
the operation is smooth but it does not
have the fulfillment bought property
like I wasn't able to write down a
convincing example so here comes
actually the important new part uncle
mattresses for four properties a
property over Oh capillary Tao is just a
class of structure close down the rice a
morphism and a boolean hankou matrix is
the infinite matrix their columns and
rows are labeled by finite structures
and inside the matrix you compute the
element oops
the element of the matrix labeled a I AJ
is one if we only if the operation of
those two structures happens to have the
property and the property is fine i
drank if the corresponding infinite
matrix has finite rank over the field of
two elements or boolean field so you can
also define an equivalence relation to
arose naturally define an equivalence
relate the roast naturally define
equivalence relation my two structures
are equivalent if the evidently close
this can also be said in in the
following way a is equivalent to B with
respect to the property and the
operation for all Sigma structures if
you are now changing of a couple in
other words for town structures we have
that a combined we seized in FIFA no TV
combine bc is in fee and the property
has finite index with respect to this
operation if they're only finitely many
equivalence classes and it's easy to see
that finite index is the same as finite
rank so these are just two ways of
looking at it and actually this is
inspired by the narrowed my hero theorem
for for birds rather than structures now
why are those ankle mattress is
important well they play or the
connection matrices for connection
operations play a very important role in
the logo theory of graph limits and so
on but here is the theorem approved in
207 let Phoebe a graph property such
that the corresponding matrix has finite
rank for the K connection then fee can
be checked in polynomial time on
structures of three weeks at most K so
this is actually a cool cell theorem
which which is logic free it just says
the only thing you have to know is that
is this hunk o matrix has finite rank
for for the K connection well there is a
lemma than it is also finite right
4l connections are smaller than K and
then you can redo but in a more
complicated way the dynamic programming
argument and this works now I proved
with my my student Nadia a similar
theorem for click with with the modified
some like operation and the important
thing to note here is that there are
uncountably many graph properties which
have finite rank for a fixed operation
so so this really shows though the
argument is a bit not cheating it's true
good it depends on some indexing weather
for every subset of natural numbers you
do something but but it shows that there
are many more properties with finite
length and there are this is really a
vast improvement on encore sense theorem
now what we want to do is for every
definable property in a logical we say
that L if every property has finite rank
for sums or products on connections we
say that there is a finite s rank by
rank or so on and what what we proved
this Tomer and very godly in 2008 is
that if you have a nice fragment of
second-order logic and you have a smooth
operation then every definable property
has finite rank so that this is really
shows that there there are many more
cases where you can apply this theorem
as a consequence we get that melodic
second order and counting Mona the
executive Roddick have finite s rank and
searing canned additionally if you take
first other versions then you have also
finite product rank now the pfefferman
what property implies finite rank this
is what what is behind this proof this
is why we get this connection so we can
formulate a theorem let there be an
sleen same logic and box smooth
operation then any definable property
has finite rank and we can go on with
this and we get that if l is a favor got
property for all some like operations
then it is finite rank and what what is
left is is the following equation do we
have a converse theorem which says that
maybe in a way the saying that every
every five o'clock logic has an
extension which satisfies the
free-formin would theorem now finite
rank alone doesn't help because there
may be
not all the formulas are there so we
have to find an additional condition and
we'll take a closer look so our logic is
if it has pfefferman what property it
has the additional property that every
equivalence class in this of this having
the same browser in the matrix is itself
definable by a formula of the same
complexity so we can say logic is a box
closed if this is true in general and
the s clause be closed if it is true for
every some like products like operation
and the theorem says that the logic is
not if a logic is nice and has
development not property for all some
like operations it is as closed so so
then this is ain't that maybe we hit he
hit the right property and the main
theorem I want to present today and this
is a corrected version of its only a
misprint in the paper of serum 16 in the
birthday paper let L be a nice as closed
logic and the following or equivalent
LSD pfefferman what property force every
some like operation all some black
operations are smooth for all fee and
every some like operation the rank of he
is finite and for all fee and every son
like operation the index is finite and
the same holds for production and
connections so so this is the story I
wanted to tell and then there are some
open problems which we can look over you
can look at afterwards wherever they
gave me at me
okay though the main open problem is
there a logic who's definable properties
are exactly the ones of finite rank and
what you can try to do is they say take
take your logic take all the other
things which are definable and and add
them as generous quantifiers but it's
not clear how you how you how you have
to define the gender the rank function
to make everything work so so this is
what we overlooked in the paper we
thought somehow we had a definition of
this rank function which which which
doesn't work so okay this is this is
basically what i have to say arizona
stila proof that there are many more
classes of structures which have h have
finite drink for a fixed operation but
it's not clear that you have that many
classes of structure which are fine a
drink for every for every operation
thank you very much
getting that club thank you again